that was very very nicely done thank you
very much I'm Larry martes the former
president of the overseas press club and
I'm welcoming you now tonight to the
club Alexis gelber the current incumbent
wanted me to do that is anything
happening here yes all right in any case
we are privileged to have a wonderful
event tonight and a great turnout for it
back in 1971 a an event happened of many
of us remember it with still with a
sense of shock a helicopter went down
over Laos and four of the best
photographers and the business went with
it the best known was Larry boroughs of
life with him wer kennt Potter of the
ascent of United Press International on
way of Associated Press and case oberto
shimamoto of Newsweek where I was
working at the time it was a major event
for horse pass and Richard pile the
shock never went away and what happened
after that was that after 27 years they
decided they would go back find out as
much as they could about what had
happened there and tell the story the
book they've written is full of
reminiscences of the Vietnam War great
inside stories and it's a kind of
meditation on what journalists do and
why they do it Horst vas is a member of
the overseas press club he is also
the associated press photo editor for
Europe Asia and the Middle East based in
London he is won two Pulitzer Prizes and
our own robert capa award for courage in
photography Richard pile covered the
Vietnam War for the AP for five years
and was bureau chief in Saigon from 1972
1973 since then he has covered many
places around the world both of the
authors are on their second book so this
is their second book and we are very
privileged to have them with us here
tonight I guess Richard will begin I
guess that what I should do to begin
with is to give you a little idea about
why this book came about when when this
it's all in the book but I'll give you a
quick recap when this event happened I
was in Saigon Bureau we knew that don t
was argue it was going to be going into
allows we hope that he was because the
press had been denied access to that
battlefield for the first time in the
vietnam war the Americans and the South
Vietnamese usually followed the American
lead had decided that the press could
not go and cover this battle they found
some obscure law that said well if
there's a you can't go across an
international border and a military
aircraft if there's a commercial service
available or there was no commercial
service available in that area it
probably never had been but that didn't
matter it was a technicality and they
used it but anyway on the third day of
this operation is this brave but flawed
idea to to invade Laos and that has any
residence for you I can't help you the
the South Vietnamese invaded allows to
try to cut the Ho Chi Minh Trail which
was the North Vietnamese supply line to
the Southern battlefields the press was
denied access to this the American
military was serving only in a support
capacity providing logistics and
helicopter support so forth we couldn't
get aboard any aircraft to go into Laos
but on the
third day the commander of the operation
general general LOM decided that he
needed to get some good press for this
thing because it wasn't going all that
well so he arranged allowed some
journalists to go with him on a
battlefield tour and these four guys
Larry burrows are you at kent potter and
Casey borough shimamoto were there
waiting and because of their seniority
and they're standing in the press corps
they just by the pecking order got the
seats on the helicopter helicopter
fluent allows that made one stop at a
firebase and then on the second leg
between the first and second leg the the
helicopters went too far over the Ho Chi
Minh Trail into it what officers later
said was the most dangerous
anti-aircraft fire they had ever seen in
the entire war they got shot down and
and they were all killed we knew that
right from the start that they were
probably all dead there was not much
hope of anything because there was a
fireball American pilots had seen this
and told us told our guys what had
happened but the site wasn't known we
didn't know exactly where it was and
there was not any hope of getting there
or doing anything about this at the time
I remember that about two days after
this happened I had the first the first
time I had the thought that someday
somebody would go to find that place and
if that were to happen I wanted that to
be me all of you he what was one of my
closest friends and larry was a good
friend and Kent was a good friend I
didn't actually know shimamoto very well
I'd seen him but I didn't know him but
this went on for the end of the war
lasted another four years it ended the
Communists won the curtain the bamboo
curtain came down all over Indochina
there was no way to get access to this
area for 25 years there was no way to
get access till the early 1900s 1990s
rather i should say what century am I
and in the early 1990s a diplomatic
agreement was made which allowed the
United States for the first time to go
into Indochina and start searching for
its military mi A's
in a serious manner 1994 this case had
slipped through the cracks because there
was no US military involvement there
were no American military people on his
helicopter there were seven South
Vietnamese military people and there
were four foreigners and the only
American among them was a civilian by a
series of amazing occurrences and
coincidences this came to the attention
of the search unit which is based in
Hawaii and a guy there who saw this
researched it discovered that Kent
Potter with a boy from Philadelphia he
was American citizen and that
technically qualified this case to be
put on their list for investigation that
was in nineteen sixty 96-94 in 96 they
searched for that site they found what
they thought was the site they found
they had three or four failed attempts
and finally found the site they found
pieces of film and pieces of cameras in
such profusion that there was every
indication in the circumstantial
evidence that this was the place you can
imagine after 27 years you're finding
film in the jungle and still there the
emulsion is all gone unfortunately but
it's film and it's 35 millimeter film
and the cameras are 35 millimeter film
of the kinds that these guys carried
pieces of them blends is and stuff so
two more years went by and I had
established connections with these
people in Hawaii and said if this ever
happens if you ever go there I want to
go there too and when it came down in
early nineteen ninety-eight we got the
word horse and I that we were going to
be able to go and it was a rush job and
I flew from New York horse flew from
London to Bangkok we rendezvous in
Bangkok he flew from London where he's
based I flew from New York by way of
Korea at 26 our flight knocked on the
door his hotel room at midnight in
Bangkok and I knew then when he opened
the door this was a go we were really
going to do this up to that point I had
never been sure it was ever going to
happen next day we flew to Laos we went
out to the site we spent four days out
there with the team in the jungle in
what horse referred to as the most
remote place on earth and I swear it it
was
and we came away satisfied in our own
minds that we had been to the place and
we had fulfilled the purpose that we set
out to and that was just to to go there
and that's essentially the story the
book there's more to come on this story
it's not over yet and I can talk about
that a little later in questions but I
want to turn this over to my esteemed
colleague here who is a man that a world
famous man and when the time came to
choose a partner for this project there
wasn't anybody else that I would ever
have chosen to be my partner on this
thing but horse fuss for me of course
the sorry I'll turn it off so you was
Peter on it why not when he has to say
we didn't know you'd like to know I have
it on tape it's an exclusive well never
live it down one of the one of the
things I've tried to do when 75 came was
cut Vietnam out of my system I've been
there 10 12 years maybe 10 years with a
few years a few months or years on other
assignments but 75 came and I saw this
is it and I'll dedicate myself now to
the Palestinians and Africa again in
London and BSE NSYNC Lakeland but of
course the people that that worked was
in Vietnam State stayed in my head and
stayed behind so vile which I talked
about the the events that led us to
98 and the discovery of this helicopter
at me the minister little bit on on the
people involved the first one on the
scene was really Larry boss he was
already there when I arrived wispy
darnet by the way in june nineteen sixty
two allari had been sent to do the
definitive take out on what we had nam
was all about and by january sixth
eastleigh he published in life 24-page
as in layout in color and
black-and-white on what we had numbers
was really like and he showed in these
many pages what we were trying over the
next years and years to show again and
again for daily newspapers larry larry
was the men who saw vietnam first and
showed to the world what what it was
like clear and definitive and sharp and
without polemics without politics larry
from day one was was the leader of the
go power our mentor in a way well there
was also angry you would already and i
quickly noted him he worked at the time
for a united press international and was
a seduction of a few dollars I got him
over to two of the associated press but
not many dollars
at a time when when ap had had lost the
first photographer was a Vietnamese went
on me Larry bounced in and out of my
life we visited the AP went to parties
together he always better dress and
anybody else and he would also admonish
us to keep it calm and be cool and talk
too much about it father take pictures
it was always a good relationship we
have many pictures of Larry at various
parties where he talks to us the older
men to the younger ones the angry you it
was well stifling Hollywood I think
never showed up on parties might be on a
Christmas dinner he stood dinner that he
would never show at parties he was he
was a serious worker and and he had a
good sense of humor and he was quite
cultured and pleasant to be about and
present to have him around him he showed
up at AP and I think for the six years
or so he six six and a half years he
worked for AP I must have edited every-
fee for almost every negative he ever
shot photographers would go out in the
field and they would select their own
and netted i would but i would always
look at the rest of it and look at it
again and find a lot of material and
there was nobody as reliable as as only
he could go anywhere he would always
come back for surprising pictures
pictures had always published i think he
after all these years only for me is was
all respect to larry the photographer
vietnam and looking through his
negatives for the do my research for
Vicky am convinced me of this and and I
hope one day we can be here and and
launch a book on hungry can Potter was a
different generation likely most of the
UPI crowd he stood out a little bit
because it was a bit more forceful he
would get up earlier and we would be
everywhere
hit hard and and was was a danger to AP
we we we had a we had a good competition
going and bless ap like their UPI that
kept us on our toes and Kent was one of
these young men that kept us on our toes
in later years of the war shimamoto as
you say I met him here Madame de and a
company of his Japanese colleagues but
he was a bit of a mysterious man the
only thing I knew from somebody is that
he was in Tokyo as a child during the
firestorms and that it I think I recall
that we talked about this once because i
was in berlin during the bombing and
they posted a great appreciation upon me
we still have so i knew these people and
they were part of my life and I
respected them whatever life there have
been a lot of strange coincidences in
regards of this story I never forget
meeting Larry and Calcutta in generally
late general I 71 he was there to do
something similar as I did poverty and
Calcutta and problems in India but he
was also working on on documents to
illustrate the 200-year anniversary are
saying of the East India Company and we
talked about how difficult it is to
photograph oil paintings in a museum or
difficulties took place a light
something out could never do what he
explained to me how it learned it in
London and it's much more difficult and
take a picture in the field in Vietnam
almost simultaneously we got we got word
that there's something big happening on
the northern border was Laos and he had
gotten his marching orders and the AP
said you better get back to Saigon as
soon as possible we have an emergency
something big is coming up
he packed his bag I packed my bag he had
a visa to vietnam I didn't I had to go
to Singapore and waste its Lee days to
get a visa 34 days well finally arrived
in in Saigon there was a day when he
crashed if I would have had a visa I
would have certainly been along because
that's the way we often did it traveling
to the same area and then sharing a
little bit because we were not competing
with each other so thank God the
Vietnamese bureaucracy kept me from
being on that helicopter of course
that's a thought that went through my
mind many times when I walked on there
well during the after after war after
Vietnam for years I didn't ignore
Vietnam I returned there once in 1978
and as an East German tourists and got
some good stories about the tunnels when
they were not not a tourist site and had
my first contact was Vietnamese we had
Cong and North Vietnamese photographers
and officials and then how they turned
later on was more toes in bloom to do a
story on the Ho Chi Minh Trail we were
already talking about this project here
in welches book and I made it about 60
miles to that point on foot was an old
truck and on foot to get pictures and do
that story of course this was nauseous
Vietnam and and then into south vietnam
it got me the closest to to the site
when when which had told me the
background of the of the research yet on
and asked me if we can team up on this
of course I said wonderful that's that
something we just have to do for the
sake of on the end Larry and all the
others and so here we went it was an
adventure i enjoyed it like i enjoyed
many of my vietnam i must say he had a
good time in Laos and and always and we
it was it was emotionally a strenuous
but satisfactory that effectively
experienced to land on this hill and do
something and find something once we are
there once we are there it was was like
reporting always is we counted the
pieces of shrapnel and of camera and
film and I don't know often i answered
Panthers question kansas film still be
developed we found the leica that is
published in this book that must have
belonged to Larry I went to lights in
Germany and identified the number and
savored state and so on it was reporting
at its best and I enjoyed it and and
there was out of it is quite detailed as
longer than any AP 20 story should be
but here is deep pick up again yeah the
in the course of writing this book there
were a lot of bits and pieces that had
to be brought together from what we had
before for lives of these guys and we
knew the only one we really could it was
fairly easy to to do the story on Larry
because his son Rosalyn wife Bobbie live
here in town and his mother Ozols mother
live here and so Russell was very
helpful to me in helping to fill out the
blanks or larry was concerned a lot of
things that we otherwise would not have
known about Larry Bruce in honorees case
he had siblings in France and with Horst
doing a lot of really good legwork and
one of our guys in Paris guy capella
what's we got a lot of good stuff about
honor me Jim emoto's brother listen is
quite elderly he was in Japan and he had
on to the crash site right after we were
there and a little Buddhist ceremony so
we had some stuff about shimamoto from
him and also from a guy who wrote an
essay about Jim amota which was
published Kent Potter the American was
in some ways the hardest he had only one
relative sister who chooses not to
discuss any of this so she doesn't and
we don't bother her I was at a loss as
soon as to how to find out about Kent's
childhood in Philadelphia we knew only I
knew him from Vietnam I knew that he was
a Quaker I knew that he was in
Philadelphia I didn't know much more
about him because Kent never discussed
his family and they read the book ii
will see there are some reasons why that
is but i was really distressed over the
fact that i couldn't get any access to
any information about Kent that could
help me fill in this part of his story
because I wanted to do a thorough
biographical chapter as much as thorough
as possible in each one of them one day
about three years ago or I forget how am
i hears it two or three years ago I was
working sundays ntap and I got a phone
call from Denmark it was a young woman
I'll hold she's now but she said she
asked goodbye Richard pile I said yes
and she said I'm trying to find you I
said why is that she says you're writing
something about Kent Potter and I said
yeah I'm writing a book what do you know
Kent Potter she says I was Kent Potter's
last high school sweetheart I said don't
go away
she told me her name is Anne bathgate
Walker she had been his classmate of
Kent's and they'd had a high skool luv
affair and so forth and then she went
off and married a Danish exchange
student and but she always carried this
torch for Kent I won't go into the
details you can read it in the book but
it's an incredible story about about
this relationship that they had and how
she never gave up the idea she's still
in love with Kent to this day and she
told me that she booked me she first
talked to me she said I believe that
he's still alive and he's somewhere out
there in Southeast Asia he's dying of
cancer in some hut with some woman and
his children and I'd like to go find him
I want to go find I said before you go
any further and I said let me screw your
way on this that the helicopter was a
fireball everybody died Kent Potter's
not alive he's dead and there's no
reason to think otherwise but I would
like to have you tell me the story of
camp hotter she did that she told me in
great detail baring her soul really in a
way that you would never expect anybody
to do to tell me the story of Kent
Potter as a as a boy as a young man and
she put me in touch with a lot of other
people who were friends of Kent's and I
threw her and these connections i was
able to put this story of Kent's
childhood together there was a lot of I
left out but what's they're really
really gives you the idea what but this
guy was like and and you get the sense
of it i did and i think that you may if
Kent bought her who was only 23 years
old when he died he was the youngest
accredited correspondent in the Vietnam
War when he first came there in 1968 he
was like Barry 20 real hot ticket and I
believe that if Kent had lived to a ripe
old age that he would be up with honry
and Larry and Horst and some others as
as one of the preeminent
photojournalists of our time and I've
often thought about this and it's how
war takes away young people soldiers and
so forth
at the beginning of their lives and in
Kent's case this was also true and it
makes it even more important to me and
what I said in the book that these
people are remembered in ways that most
people are not they have left a legacy
of their work to this day we open the
magazine we see a picture by Lori
burrows Hall Hewitt we see Shem emoto's
material if we're in the right place
unfortunately there's not as much of a
compendium of stuff as there is with the
others but we see Kent Potter's pictures
and can't left a memorial to himself in
his work that's how all these guys did
and I felt that that is one reason that
they need to be written about was that
people need to know that this this
material exists these guys are still
alive live on through their work which
is something that not everybody has the
opportunity to have have a legacy like
that and I think I said in the book it
was more important than any tombstone
and I really feel that that's true that
that's one way of reconciling ourselves
to the loss of people like these guys is
that we could look at that and say they
have a they have a legacy that that is
not available to most people
well AP photographer Hollywood we found
a lady living in Stockholm who lives up
to the stave as five suitcases full of
the leftovers of what was cleared out of
his apartment in Saigon in 1971 they
were engaged at the time and none of us
knew it none of us knew he had this
relationship and it was a very secretive
person but we found her and she invited
me to come up to Stockholm and she
opened up the suitcases for she said the
first time in years and years and to my
surprise he had kept every AP World
magazine and Avery a copy of every story
he ever wrote and many of his
photographs it was a wonderful source of
of his life at the AP and it was kept in
good order in addition there were long
letters poems paintings things we didn't
know all he was doing goes on he was a
person who just showed up at the AP
office maybe on a weekend to slee days
and then he would go out again he would
go to war like other people go to the
office and only that he wouldn't come
back at night you would spend five days
out there and then come back was most
incredible film and stories was
debriefed went to his apartment that I
think you had to clean out and and
otherwise we didn't know much about him
so when I saw na jana home bar and
Stockholm I learned was in one weekend
more about Harvey when I I saw every
week for years and years and then and
all the time we worked together very
strange experience there's a one of the
things that I didn't I could have
written about another book the same
length if I'd had the room to do it I
never thought so many times since this
book is finished that there were so many
things that I probably should have put
into it that I didn't but it might have
made it too long and cumbersome but one
of the things
I learned as a young journalist I
learned almost everything I know about
journalism i think in Vietnam and I
learned it from these people was the
relationship the symbiotic relationship
between reporters and photographers in a
place like that you have a symbiotic
relationship here in New York work with
photographers I'll go out with the betta
or somebody and we go on an assignment
and we hang out and we come back and we
we go our separate ways basically we're
working two things but in Vietnam we had
a relationship in the bureau in the AP
Bureau and I'm sure it was true
elsewhere other bureaus that you worked
so closely together that you became
always a team you were a unit and the
ideal thing was to have a reporter and a
photographer go together what's the way
we did it we was split up doing it we
want for a day or whatever it was or two
days split up and go to at different
units and then rendezvous later this way
we would double the story because the
photographers we all carried cameras we
carried a suite of cameras that horse
faas devised Leica's and nikons and i
learned to shoot pictures with with
these cameras i learned to be a
photographer I got pictures published
like others did and the photographer's
new to interview people get names and
ages and hometowns and all that business
and to take notes and come back and
while honry Hewitt was not a writer
English was a language in which he was
fearless but a little shaky he would we
would debrief honry or other guys and we
would sit down and write these stories
under there by lines and I must have
written 15 stories under re it was by
line and the amazing thing about it was
that I could usually write it off of his
photo caption material and a few
questions because he was such a reporter
his eyes saw everything and recorded
everything he wasn't the only one but he
was the best and you could write a story
off of what the photographer told you
you didn't have to have there were no
there were no gaps in it it was there it
was if you had been there yourself this
relationship there with photographers
and reporters is one that I probably
valued more than any
thing else that I ever did in journalism
and I did it only one other place and
that was in Lebanon with a guy who's
here tonight mr. Kuhn doc Jian back
there was my my colleague in Lebanon he
tried to kill me every day but managed
it so he could rescue me is it literally
true but up this was this was a thing
that I think that a lot of reporters go
through the lives and never quite have
the experience of having the symbiotic
connection with with photographers and I
feel as if I understand photographers
better than most reporters and it's not
easy but I think they do and and one
reason why I felt comfortable about
writing this book I mean I felt sure of
my material and share of my
understanding of what these guys did
because I had spent so much time in this
relationship with them working
relationship with these guys you may
have the forcer that includes you by the
way bless what yeah oh you can yeah yeah
well Richard and Horst after after a
moment for technical services Richard
and Horst would like to answer your
questions let me lay down a couple of
ground rules first please identify which
of them you want to answer the question
second ask questions do not make
speeches and third no multi-part
questions thank you very much we'll have
the boom now and wait for my we're on a
test pattern
why did you do this book editor right
way in 30
cooler Bernie after you did the Requiem
book horst why did you do this book
difficult to answer we be tried not to
do another like vm book well of course
like film has been on my mind which had
helped us was like um writing about the
case Requiem didn't give enough space to
go into the lives of people and here in
this book we try to sketch out the the
lives and the lives of the upbringing
and the background of these four
photographers in in greater depth to
make leaders people understand what made
them to become photographers but their
dedication was why they did it what they
what they saw on their profession I
wanted to show also a bit more of what
they achieved and a bit more of their
legacy but you're told now that picture
books are not in any more because that
production is too expensive so the
picture content of this book is limited
to happily 48 pages as could have been
less so it's not a picture book as like
we haven't an expensive presentation as
this memorial was it is more of a study
of four fascinating characters that were
sewn together by fate this is answer
for both of you hundreds of your
colleagues are in the field in Iraq and
surrounding countries this week what are
your thoughts about them I mean the
embeds laterals the independent okay
well first the embeds the the Johnny I
don't know why the Pentagon you're an
old Washington guy you should be able to
convince the Pentagon to stop making up
these stupid words for things like embed
I was embedded in Albanian 1999 with a
with a military unit there the first
time I ever heard the word and it wasn't
very satisfactory there either but well
maybe more so there was no war so it was
not satisfactory but here this is an
amazing step forward that they have
taken to put all these people into the
field and you're getting a you're
getting of this war up close and
personal but you're getting it in in
microbursts you're getting it a little
bit here a little bit there and it's all
very graphic and very well reported but
there's so much of it that it's a you
can almost have combat fatigue from
watching television and and it's hard to
get a grip on the picture of what is
really taking shape in Iraq if you rely
only on the m beds and the material it's
coming from the and the unilateral for
that matter and the briefings of course
which are supposed to pull it all
together have so far proven totally
useless and so this war is being
thoroughly reported thoroughly covered
with a lot of very courageous people
many of whom have never done this before
and they're seeing a lot more war in a
short time and many people in Vietnam
ever saw but i think that the there has
to be some way to pull this all together
and make it a little more coherent so we
get a better idea of exactly what is
taking shape in the bigger picture and
so far we don't have that we have some
extremely good reporting from a lot of
excellent people
either one who wants to do you think the
art of the still photographer is has is
diminished now and in war now that we
have video and it seems to be that's
used almost solely except for you know
you means the video as opposed to stills
yeah or that the impact of the still
photographers diminished those are
always going to be the most impact I
think the what I think the power still
photographers still photography is
bigger than ever before today we see
more publications than ever publications
are printed in perfect quality think of
this striped and dotted pictures of the
Vietnam Mia they are immediately
available and they're powerful compare
this with television at fleet doesn't
flutters I arrived here last night in
that tight last night to get get some
idea what happened during my flight from
London I couldn't find out on television
I'd advise on New York Times this
morning to get an idea of what it is and
see look at the New York Times a
full-page never happened food page of
photos and each one expressive sleep
pictures on the front page wonderful
picture that shows fighting on a bridge
couldn't have taken it better in Vietnam
at any time so the photos are getting
better and i think the leaders are
grateful for seeing these pictures 12
hours later or 10 hours or whatever
because it makes them understand a bit
more about the event it's not coming in
bursts of shouted television bits and
pieces i call it sound sound bites and
so on it's it's coming as a concentrated
bit of information these photographers
shoot many more pictures and we ever did
in the old days but there's always one
or two in there that are really powerful
and believe me the young photographers I
know that are going to these places now
they have studied play balls and
and only wit they are buying the books
that were published recently including
us let's book on on larry and their
studies these pictures and they learn
from them and they're tied to be like
the boss and they try to be better like
bars and was the equipment they have
today that wonderful digital equipment
the long lenses and so they are better
than bars have better than we were no
question photography was advanced during
the Vietnam days than ever since I sing
in a scone and I i I'm a believer in the
future of a photography as long as it
isn't a mixed up with as a commercial
part as a advertising and as long as not
too many non journalists meddle in
publications that poor one when I hear
this question asked a lot crescent and
people want wonder about the impact of
television versus stills I always felt
that the still photo has much more
impact and I use as an example the two
most famous pictures of the Vietnam War
one was the picture Eddie Adams picture
of the general shooting the guy in the
head and the other one is a Nichols
picture of the little napalm girl
running down a road people may not
realize or remember that both of those
events were also televised there was
live there was there was television film
of both those events but what you
remember today is those pictures because
you turn the page of a magazine now and
there's that picture again you've seen
it a hundred times and there it is it's
a fixed image it's what John Morris at
the time is called frozen image it's
what is burned into your consciousness
you don't remember what that television
film was like it was pretty graphic for
one thing he didn't show it too much but
you may see it on occasion but that's
not what people remember people remember
those events and they become iconic
events because of the still photos and
that because television was there you
and horse has just said today on CNN mr.
turnley was interviewed by CNN and they
showed a terrific segment of his still
images that he basically talked about
and between eating breakfast standing up
at my kitchen deck and listening to the
a very repetitive music to CNN I stopped
to listen not here but listen to mr.
turn lay and looked the images so they
dedicated a segment of quite a few
minutes to his terrific coverage and
still photographs I think it's true that
the best the most memorable stuff coming
out of this this war like the others is
to still pictures like that one on the
cover of The Times the day what horse
said about that is Ashley right that's a
picture that there could have been taken
in Vietnam and it's it's a picture every
newspaper in the country used that
picture are those soldiers on that
bridge when embedded was one unit we
slept in many beds well your self horse
when when something when something
happened to e we just moved along and
try to get to the place where news
happened today at and at the time so we
were free to abandon a unit that became
a blocking force and could jump on a
helicopter and leave out a bit hitchhike
for day and then reach the unit that was
involved in in advancing on in ambush on
unit to which something had happened
these poor guys in the embedding system
there sit there as a blocking foursome
once they leave they have to go all the
way back to Washington us and get a new
position so if you have 20 photographers
out there is 20 units and it's it's a
21st unit that makes contact that comes
a zoom in on this unit with the numbers
involved that's very difficult to do and
I can understand the military that they
can't have 500 photographers when when
the moline shoot up a possible civilians
account comes us all come there but I
see that as a great great problem in
this system and feel sorry for the poor
guys that a 500 yards of 50 kilometers
away from from where the real action s
and can't move Horst I wonder if you
could talk about the motivations of the
four photographers in the book and
whether you think those say
motivations inspire young men and women
today to become photographers in great
numbers miss pika of first about the
motivation of our subjects I can't say
much for shimamoto because I didn't see
enough of his material and not all that
much was published and of course
Newsweek has no no memory of shimamoto
is not a single picture and their files
I know that I know that Larry Larry and
how he really believed in what they were
doing and there are like likely those of
us who survived we had the feeling that
we did something that was important and
what was important because of main thing
is to get into print but what was in
print we wanted to show to the world be
the reality of what was Vietnam it
didn't want anything filter than
anything phony and anything arranged we
wanted them to show the the realities
the realities weren't always negative
there was a lot of flavor Lee and there
was a lot of heroism and there was a lot
of good work and the military they were
also the negative things of Kosovo's
this endless torture that was committed
by most Vietnamese unit there was a
stupidity there was a bombing miss
bombing and and all that there was a
friendly fire a lot of things that the
military of course wouldn't like us to
show what we showed it because it wasn't
singular it was it happened all the time
and and we felt good about it and we
felt we were we were believing in our in
the good reason for our profession when
when these features of the wall came
through and discussions began about
about these aspects of the war
very early in the wall I witnessed a lot
of a lot of torture committed by the
South Vietnamese mainly the Rangers
mainly in the in the Delta and I had
quite a lot of difficulties with
managing editors here in the US about
these photos and because it wasn't me
who got the complaints that was my land
boss how buell the issue was always why
does this guy photograph torture why
doesn't he photograph when we distribute
food or treat wounded or aid the montney
arts and how came back and we discussed
this endlessly and I hawt hold up
incidents and France we photographed
also we had constable tality and
terrorism in Saigon but my my point was
always I wouldn't see it I would ignore
it if it happens once a week or it
happens just around the corner and just
one men doing it the accidental casual
that I witness that every day and I
thought it's such an important feature
of of warfare that that it as a dozen or
it was as good and it did the Vietnamese
in there were there were the Vietnamese
population of course didn't didn't run
over to the government's I they stuck it
out to the Viet Cong and as the
conditions have faced when their
villages were were taken by South
Vietnamese so we continued photographing
and showing it and after a while these
scenes were accepted and there was a
discussion in in the US and on the world
that these photos may be doing one a bit
of good one day well not in Vietnam I
had something something similar in in
Pakistan the Meech lor and I I
photographs is horrible bio netting of
five prisoners in December 70
seventy-two 72 a lot of people said all
you were invited for an execution and
whether you take these horrible pictures
and we are very distraught after this
event really shaking and difficulties
accepting what we just saw the pictures
were published and caused the storm and
caused a lot of criticism but I learned
much later that mrs. Indira Gandhi who
was who was in prime minister of india
all of the troops in bangladesh and his
pakistan to immediately take measures to
stop all such events in the newly
occupied territory so she was upset
about the photographs and we upset for
once a white person would have been
going on a bit this is answer I used to
worry before I was beer chief and even
more so after I took that job that the
focus was so much on the american war
that we didn't give sufficient attention
coverage to the south vietnamese i look
back on night now and i realized that
wasn't really the case we did a
tremendous amount of coverage at the
south vietnamese i would say we did more
than than most and what horst is talking
about was early in the game when the
Americans weren't there yet so there was
even it was very intensive then but even
later on and one one way that I reached
the conclusion that we weren't derelict
in this was that when I realized that of
the four AP staffers who were killed in
Vietnam they were all photographers by
the way three of them went I me Bernie
colon Berg and honry Hewitt were with
South Vietnamese forces when they were
killed and Ollie Noonan who was a boy
from Boston photographer that Horst
hired as a as a local hire there's a
tremendous guy he and I were out
together the day he was killed and they
we were with an American force and Ali
was the only one of the four who was was
with Americans when he died and so for
what it's worth we the casualty that we
took were in the service of trying to
report what the South Vietnamese and not
the Americans were doing the second part
of your question the photographer's of
today well just look at the pictures
that are coming out of the occupied
territories in Israel often photographed
by Palestinian photographers they
believe that believe in the power of
photography believe me they they want to
show what's happening and their
territory they want to show the
frustrations of that people and they are
damn good reporters are not politically
minded there's slate forward and when
you meet them one to one in London or
maybe meet them here they're just like
just like we were in these days as
they're not at all politically now what
they're not our farts men they want to
be reporters and they have an urge to
tell the story and believe it or not we
have a young photographer not so young
but a photographer in Baghdad I met a
few months ago and he's made of the same
this is the same mold he he takes
pictures and he wants to show what's
happening and he cannot show everything
we talked about showing the the impact
of the sanctions and so on and he talked
to me about the restrictions but believe
me he he he bought the requiem book well
he was there from this money he looked
at it he talked endlessly about
photography and he sinks that's his job
in in Baghdad is before the war is very
important for the world that somebody
shows what's going on there isn't that
isn't that reason to take this
especially I do hard work I think we we
have this today as we had it 40 years
ago and and and I hope books like this
help help people to orientate themselves
newly and
look look back into the past and ahead
in the future at the same time and
become even better people better
photographers and reporters I'd like to
hear from each of you what your most
significant memory of Vietnam is what
has stayed with you more than anything
else you're mostly remember if you had
nom no horse has been a long time there
must have been difficult reaction I'd to
my Vietnam experiences was when I was
not in Vietnam 1975 I felt we we
betrayed our friends when VZ foreigners
who had come there and stayed there and
promise the world and pulled out and the
AP stayed behind but then we had to move
out and it was a very very sad
experience to be back there in 78 and
meet some of the photographers and
cameramen and not be able to talk to
them because I was still under strict
who also that 78-75 experience of April
May was depressing and impaired anybody
who who had been there and I'm i know
that many military if people felt like
that people that had been there and
tried to do some good day and try to
have success air felt that that was
failure and was betrayal in a way many
of the many of the military that I meet
today are still proud of what they did
in these late years of the war that
comes out in this book his helicopter
pilots didn't have to list their lives
and emails ever on the way home in 71
many of their infant Lee colleagues had
already gone home they had no reason to
fly into the Vietnamese bases and rescue
Vietnamese Ranger
photographers or anything but they did
and they incurred great losses ever they
were real real heroes in a way because
the political situation was already
solved and that washed their hands but
his heart was still their time to help
him there there helped was more further
and more more commitment than at any
other time before the war billion I mean
speaking about the helicopter pilots who
you encountered we met since some of the
most amazing people that I have met in
my life were people that I met in
Vietnam and includes some helicopter
pilots including something we met
originally I guess that the if I have to
stop and think about what it was about
Vietnam it was the strange grip that
this place had on people and almost
anybody who was there during the time of
the war and so forth journalists I'm
speaking of basically but it doesn't
necessarily have to limit itself to that
it had a kind of a hypnotic or narcotic
effect that you just felt as if this was
the place where you had to be I felt
this way that if I hadn't done this gone
there and done whatever it was necessary
to do this that I would have missed out
on a the most important part of my life
it and it turned out to be the case
looking back on it I think that that
would have been true the things that
made it so attractive and so magnetic
were the setting this tropical setting
with the sense of mystery and danger and
all that business it's all there I mean
is you can really romantic out the
window and and this is true but the most
important thing that I look back now and
think about it was that the most the
best friends I ever made I made in
vietnam
friends that 30 years later are still my
friends I see a guy here tonight sit in
the front row i haven't seen but maybe
three or four times since vietnam and
it's a it just it's wonderful to see him
i mean we can meet each other every four
or five years and there's some sort of a
secret invisible handshake passes
between us that we both know without
having to say anything what the
communication is there i suppose there
are other things that people do in life
that where this effect kicks in but it
for us it was vietnam and the
camaraderie of the of the press corps
the camaraderie of the bureau of being
together in this crucible of in this
place where where the excitement the
uncertainties and even the daily work
the jury of it was important i'm also
remember how fast the time went because
we never took days off we worked seven
days a week we took our and ours
periodically with we always were post
pointing those things so we didn't get
as much time off as we probably were
titled to but we didn't want to if you
had a day off in saigon you'd come in
the office and hang out start working
because that was what you did it was a
totally absorbing in developing a
experience that you didn't just do it it
wasn't just a job it was it was
something that it was your life it truly
enveloped you and I was there five years
and the day I left I couldn't believe it
was five years it seemed like it had
been a couple of months it went by so
fast that it's it's it's hard to cope
with the idea that all that was crammed
into at all that in five years seems
like it was a couple of months but the
best thing about it is as I said that
the the friendships that were formed
there and forged their working
relationships and friendships have
prevailed over these years and they will
always be there and all of us know that
right Joe
thank you both very much it's been a
wonderful evening and we're it in your
debt and thank you